big big news joe biden yesterday came
out
in full support of lifting patent
protections
on coronavirus vaccines to help produce
more vaccines
globally the biden administration said
that
we need a breakthrough for international
vaccination vaccination happening uh
quite well in the united states and well
in a few other countries
but there are lots of countries that
don't even have vaccines on the
immediate horizon right now
and joe biden has now said let's do it
let's suspend
intellectual property protections
uh to ramp up vaccine production and
this is something joe biden has been
increasingly under pressure
to say it's not doesn't
appear to be something joe biden can
actually do
but the reasoning is clear we have a
global health crisis
these are extraordinary circumstances we
need to produce as many doses as quickly
as possible and this would be a case
where
while you can respect conceptually
intellectual property protections and
patents and copyright
you can make the case this particular
situation
warrants lifting those protections now i
have to tell you for me there are two
stories here
first of all is the story that
joe biden is being pushed left i mean at
this point
on paper this may be the most
progressive administration in history i
i
i we have to understand what we're
comparing to
but this is something that big pharma
was completely against
they uh got expensive lobbyists pushing
for it
not to be done for there to be no
lifting of patents
and while joe biden can't actually do it
biden standing up to them and saying
this should be done
is a really big deal if you look at joe
biden's position on health care
it's to the left of obama if you look at
joe biden's position on taxation it's to
the left of obama
on paper this may be the most
progressive administration in history
now
we're we've never had you know bernie
has never been president
so we have to understand what that means
for those who said joe biden could not
be pushed left
uh he clearly has been at least to some
degree now here's my concern about this
entire vaccine thing
vaccine patent thing i agree that the
patents
should be lifted i agree that as many
places as possible should be given
whatever they need to start
manufacturing vaccines as quickly as
possible
there's no question whatsoever that
being said
i don't think the lifting of patents is
actually going to get us
out of this mess why in researching what
it would take
for places that are not yet producing
vaccines to start producing vaccines
you could be looking at two years of
time
to build the infrastructure to produce
vaccines
if you start today so while i agree that
the patents should be lifted and
there are reasons for the future that it
would be great to set that precedent in
a global pandemic and all
i'm with it i'm with you i think this is
a great thing that joe biden has said
if it takes two years to build the
infrastructure if you don't have it to
start producing vaccines if you start
today
and who could start today you've got to
find locations you have to
figure out where are these factories
going to go if it takes
four months to start and then it takes
two years to do
and then the entire vaccine production
and distribution would take several more
months
we are looking at new vaccine production
if patents are lifted today that
wouldn't deliver vaccines until the end
of 2023 it's just too late i don't want
to be a party pooper i don't want to
reign
on anybody's parade but it's not clear
to me
that this is anything more than um
at least for the next two years a
theoretical or academic question
it should be done and for the future
pandemic
i'm with it again i'm with it i'm with
it plea please don't write to me saying
david how dare you be against it no i'm
for it
but when i see all these people on
facebook saying we could just get out of
this if the vaccine patents were lifted
moderna did say it won't enforce its
patent there's other aspects of the
production
that moderna doesn't control which have
intellectual property protections i get
that
uh i just don't see how this gets us out
of the pandemic any sooner
um if i'm missing something let me know
the right decision
uh i don't actually think it will get
vaccines into people's
arms any sooner for this pandemic let me
know your thoughts i'm on twitter at
deepakman
quick break great show today if you are
anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat
this is not a random doctor on call each
doctor at steady md
has a limited number of patients so they
actually have time to listen to you
you get the personal attention that you
deserve they can do almost
everything an in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me
and my medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video